June is shaping up to be a great month
for new entries in long-running video
game series as Final Fantasy 16 is
almost here the latest game arrives
nearly seven years after the last
numbered entry in the mainline series
with this chapter returning to its
fantasy genre roots with a darker
medieval tale revolving around magic
political drama and War it's one of the
biggest and most highly anticipated
games on PlayStation 5 in 2023 and with
that in mind is everything you need to
know about Final Fantasy XV
Final Fantasy 16 takes place in
vallastaya a high fantasy world
embroiled in political drama focused
around dominance dominance are the few
special people who can call upon the
power of the icons which are what
summons are called in Final Fantasy 16's
World icons and dominance by extension
are akin to powerful weapons of war that
shift the balance of power between
Realms in valastaya the game will cover
three separate time frames in Final
Fantasy 16 story which you can see from
main character Clive Roosevelt's
Evolution from a spiffy young man with a
fancy haircut to a grizzled veteran with
a mark tattooed on his face later in
life the game's producer naoki Yoshida
confirmed that it will tell Clive's
story from his teens 20s and 30s Clive
is the son of his Realms Archduke and
wields icon related powers in combat but
did not inherit being the dominant of
Phoenix himself he's sworn protected his
younger brother Joshua who was fated as
Phoenix as dominant instead however
Joshua couldn't control his icon he
summons Phoenix after watching someone
presumably important get killed right
before his eyes these events are capped
by a battle between Phoenix and efrit
which might be the tragedy that drives
Clive in Final Fantasy XV another
character is Jill Warwick she is the
dominant of the icon Shiva and is said
to have a complicated life and comes
from another realm she was essentially
adopted by The Rose fields and acts as a
mediary between warring Nations Clive
will also be accompanied by his trusty
companion the dog toggle and his Pawn in
crime sadolfus telemon who's a sort of
revolutionary leader freeing the Branded
who are magic users subjugated by their
Nations he's also the dominant of ramu
and this game's version of the series
long-running character Sid Final Fantasy
16's World also revolves around mother
crystals which is said to bless the land
with ether which which is Magic nations
are built around mother crystals and
they're the Crux of political Strife but
a destructive force called the blight is
also washing over the world this will
also be the first Final Fantasy game to
receive an M rating which Square Enix
told Gamespot was an intentional move to
make a more mature story according to
the game's rating the upcoming Final
Fantasy will include sex scenes and
plenty of violence including blood
intentional deaths torture victim
suffering and hate crimes
Final Fantasy 16 takes on an action RPG
style of combat and looks like it shares
some similarities to Final Fantasy XV
and ff7 remake ryota Suzuki who was a
combat designer for Devil May Cry 5 and
Dragon's Dogma is the battle director
for Final Fantasy 16 and game director
Hiroshi takai has stated the game was
also inspired by Sony's God of War
reboot titles both in its gameplay and
the design of its semi-open world in
combat protagonist Clive can engage at
melee range with his sword and GAP
closing abilities and use elemental
powers that are tied to icons with him
picking up new ones over the course of
the game you will be able to customize
your moves to mix and match them and
swap icons in battle while Clive is the
central character and the player
protagonist he won't be the only
Adventurer on a quest Clive will be
accompanied by AI controlled party
members who will banter and connect
throughout the game as well as his
faithful buddy toggle to whom you can
give direct commands too you'll also be
able to customize Clive throughout his
Adventure by investing experience into
his skill tree and to those abilities
can be reset at any time during your
journey to explore the world players can
travel to different locations via a
world map which will be updated with new
and evolving areas as the game
progresses Final Fantasy 16 is not an
open world game and there will instead
be several open zones to explore and
dungeon-like levels to fight through
since Hideaway headquarters for Clive
will be unlocked later in the game and
is where the protagonist can upgrade his
gear buy new weapons and armor train in
a special area and pick up new side
quests Final Fantasy 16 will allow you
to tweak its difficulty but rather than
this happening through an in-game menu
you'll be able to fine tune the
challenge with five special rings that
Grant different types of assistance for
example you can simplify combat with one
ring that works by pressing one button
that automatically controls your combos
another ring extends the window for a
successful Dodge and you can equip these
rings in two of your three accessory
slots this means that you'll have to
choose which combination of rings best
suits your play style and each slot
taken up by one of the assist Rings
means one fewer accessory that you can
use to customize Clive's other abilities
the biggest new gameplay addition and
perhaps the game's biggest draw is its
icon battles Yoshida told Gamespot in an
interview that these icon battles will
all be unique one might emulate a
wrestling match while another might look
like a 3D shooter for just two examples
and estimated there are roughly 20 of
them in all
[Music]
Final Fantasy 16 is scheduled to release
exclusively for PlayStation 5 on June
22nd 2023 Square Enix has confirmed
Final Fantasy 16 is eventually coming to
PC and its PlayStation 5 exclusivity
will end December 31st 2023 while this
does not necessarily mean Final Fantasy
16 will hit PC immediately after it
theoretically could release at any point
after that date no word if the game will
eventually come to Xbox three different
in-game items are available when
pre-ordering the game but whether you
get them depends on which version you
opt for just about every retailer is
offering the cat Sith charm which boosts
the rate at which you gain Gill along
with the Braveheart weapon but the
scholars spectacles which boosts XP gain
is only available with the following
editions the digital standard and
digital Deluxe editions and the
Collector's Edition for physical
collectors Best Buy is offering a free
steelbook case with every edition of the
game the physical deluxe edition retails
for 100 and comes with a cloth world map
of balestaya and the special Clive
Rosefield steelbook case it's worth
noting that the Clive Rosefield
steelbook is different from the
steelbook offered with Best Buy
pre-orders so purchasing from that
retailer will actually net you two
unique steel books the collector's
edition of Final Fantasy 16 costs a
hefty 350 but comes with a plethora of
Collectibles that certainly make the
Steep cost worth it for Die Hard Final
Fantasy fans if you purchase the
collector's edition along with any
pre-order bonuses you'll also receive
the following a premium statue of
Phoenix vs efrit a metal icon pin
collection the special Clive Rosefield
steelbook case the cloth world map of
Alastair a bonus in-game weapon the
blood sword a digital mini art book and
mini soundtrack and the Realms of
valastair wall banners and that's
everything to know about Final Fantasy
16 before its launch on June 20 second
let us know your hype levels for the
game in the comments below and stay
tuned to Gamespot for additional Final
Fantasy 16 coverage